alors c'est là-bas peut-être surprendre
certains d'entre vous mais je joue à lol
depuis très longtemps c'était vers la
sortie quasi kz2 souvenirs vers la fin
de saison 2 où début de saison 3 mais
juste quel bonheur d'avoir enfin en 2021
et une série dédiée à l'univers après
tant d'années par cannes est vraiment
juste une master class je vous avoue que
ça fait bizarre un peu de parler de
league of legends sur la chaîne parce
que c'est un truc c'est un univers que
j'ai toujours apprécié dans mon coin
mais là en vrai l'occasion est trop
belle pour ne pas en parler on traite
beaucoup de films et de séries sur la
chaîne est là maintenant qu'il y à une
série league of legends ce serait
vraiment dommage de passer à côté donc
écoutez je vous propose de revenir sur
la fin de la première saison d'arcane et
du coup d'essayer de deviner certaines
choses théoriser un peu pour la future
saison 2 qui a été annoncé officialisé
évidemment je vais devoir spoil la série
donc vous êtes prévenus si je veux
pouvoir traiter de toutes les idées et
cetera donc voilà écoutez allons-y tout
d'abord j'aimerais commencer sur un
point que j'estime important c'est que
nous sommes dans une réalité alternative
alors c'est peut-être idiot à dire mais
cela a clairement son importance pour
mieux cerner l'oeuvre le concept de
multi verts existants soit dans league
of legends on le retrouve avec les
univers des gardiens des étoiles ou
encore l'odyssée qui sont des réalités
ou les champions ont une histoire
différente c'est même le principe des
skins à la base en soi c'est pour çà
également qu'on a le droit à des skins
dédié à la série dans le jeu arcane
possède donc son propre monde qui est
sur la même base que le lors de league
of legends mais la série est libre dans
son récit et ses interprétations
d'ailleurs le petit jeu lié à la série
nous traduisait également cette idée
mais voilà tout ça pour dire que tout
est possible dans arcanes même si un
certain respect du l'or est là tout peut
être réinterprété on le remarque déjà
toute façon avec certaines histoires de
champions comme pour joyce et victor par
exemple qui sont meilleurs potes dans la
série alors que normalement
ce n'est pas le cas bref cela va me
permettre de rebondir sur le premier
élément de la série que je voulais
traiter c'est le plan final où nous
voyons synge as i sing est plutôt
centrale dans le scénario il a créé le
chat y meurt il a travaillé avec seal qu
il est lié à beaucoup de personnages
bref et cela semble continuer avec cette
saison 2 évidemment vous l'avez tous vu
c'était la grande théorie dès l'épisode
1 puis toutes façons l'annnonce de la
saison 2 nous a attisé son thème de
chasse warwick arrive pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas trop le lors de league
of legends en grosse synge a créé
warwick ce qui explique du coup sa
présence dans le plan final où nous
voyons synge warwick était à la base un
homme un homme avec un certain vécu un
passé plutôt sanglant et qui avaient
déposé les armes pour justement arborer
une nouvelle vie vous vous en doutez il
s'agit c'est même sûr à 100% que ces
vendeurs pour être honnête étant donné
la nature d'arcane que ce soit une
réalité alternative et c'est avec la
mort entre guillemets de vendeurs dans
l'acte 1 je me disais que c'était
possiblement une réalité ou warwick ne
serait jamais né puisque vaille et son
groupe était intervenue et avait
interrompu la l'opération il s'avère
qu'au final la cij a récupéré la
dépouille de vendeurs après l incendie à
l'insu de tous puisque si le coc pense
toujours que vendeur est bel et bien
mort tout comme il nous l'a prouvé avec
jinks singh est capable de sauver des
gens clairement au bord de la mort et ce
ne serait pas abuser de dire que le
scheiner y serait pour quelque chose
d'après le plan on pourrait trouver un
autre écho à l'histoire de warwick
puisque après de multiples expériences
de transmutation signe je pense sera que
son sujet succombera à la douleur et
finira par passer à autre chose ce qui
expliquerait pourquoi warwick soeurette
immobile est suspendu dans un coin ce
qui me fait penser également ceux ci et
que rio la créature que cing maintient
en vie depuis des années grâce à la
transmutation est toujours là dans une
cuve tandis que warwick est à découvert
dans un coin sauf que tout comme dans le
nord la bête ne s'est pas encore
réveillé ce qui va être intéressant pour
la suite c'est tout l'arc narratif qui
va en découler effectivement si au
premier abord synge a finalement réussi
à faire ressortir la bête qui se cacher
dans l'homme et donc du coup que warwick
devienne un meurtrier assoiffés de sang
et bien il y aura toujours cette part
d'humanité caché au plus profond de lui
et du coup ce dernier réunira
certainement de nouveaux jinks et vas y
étend ses deux filles évidemment je
pense qu elles découvriront la vérité
derrière l'existence de warwick et cela
servira de lien du passé entre les deux
soeurs alors que la fin de la saison une
nous traduisent est une séparation
définitive
pour continuer il ya un autre point
important concernant le plan dédié à
sins c'est la fameuse photo qu'il tient
entre les mains outre l'arrivée de
warwick ce plan nous traduit également
que l'on va explorer certainement un peu
plus le personnage de synge pour la
suite des événements cette photo est
obligatoirement celle de sa fille dont
nous avons appris l'existence dans la
série on ne va pas le nier cette
dernière ressemble comme deux gouttes
d'eau à oriane a effectivement son lors
colle pas mal avec ce qu un store
arcanes et l'histoire de synge oriane à
la base c'est une pile taux viennent
tout comme site dans le nord en gros
oriana vivait avec son père du nom de
corinne et un jour un énorme accident va
arriver à zone et cela va la pousser à
vouloir aider les gens là bas
malheureusement à cause de la toxicité
de l'air provoquée par l'accident bas
oriana va tomber gravement malade
évidemment son père corinne n'acceptant
pas de perdre sa fille va tout faire
la sauver et étant en professionnel des
prothèses et des membres artificiels
il va sauver oriana en la transformant
petit à petit en dames mécanique lié à
l'ex take bref comme on la connaît
aujourd'hui quoi mais par rapport aux
réinterprétation d'arcane cela peut
clairement donné quelque chose
d'intéressant puisque si synge est le
père de rihanna est bien étant donné
qu'il est l'inventeur du chail moeurs
nos pourrions avoir une oriana qui
serait du collier aux chômeurs et non à
l'ex take le problème étant que si ns
nous fait comprendre que sa fille serait
morte et d'ailleurs cela pourrait même
être la raison de pourquoi il est autant
dévoué à la transmutation est ce que les
créateurs prendrai la décision de
changer complètement l'histoire doriana
c'est possible en revanche ce qui
m'intrigue un peu c'est que les
champions de lol présent dans la série
semble avoir une certaine immunité afin
de permettre leur évolution et surtout
justifier le récit ils sont les
personnages centraux de la série donc
voilà est ce qu'une oriana décédé avant
sa transformation existerait j'avoue que
je n'en sais trop rien néanmoins il est
clair que beaucoup d'histoires de
champions seront ré écrite dans la série
tient d'ailleurs ça me fait penser que
j'ai une petite théorie concernant un un
personnage de lol à venir pour la série
ce serait camille camille fait partie
d'une des plus puissantes familles de
piles tauber et cette dernière est très
lié à l'ex take notamment de par ses
transformations physiques pour faire
d'elle une surhumaine étant donné que
l'ex take est encore à son balbutiement
et n'est pas accessible à tous il est
clair que si camille est dans la série
elle ne serait pas encore transformé
néanmoins rien ne le prouve mais je suis
presque sûr que la famille de camille
fait partie des soutiens de jayce et
donc par conséquent qu'elle fasse partie
des premiers utilisateurs de ces travaux
en échange de financement ce qui
permettrait de justifier l'accessibilité
de camille alex tech et de la forme est
justement à devenir ce qu'elle deviendra
pour continuer il faut que nous parlions
de l'impact du final de la série pour la
suite des événements le fait que jean
xxii et cécile cau et tiré un missile
sur le conseil auront de lourdes
conséquences d'ailleurs étant donné que
son ulti est un finisher et qu'il fait
plus de dégâts s'il parcourt une longue
distance et bah je vous dis pas le
massacre
non en vrai cela va clairement attiser
la haine des piles tôt vient qui étaient
prêtes à faire la paix et cela va
sûrement donner lieu à des représailles
des représailles qui ne seront pas au
goût de victor effectivement victor
vient de la basse ville et malgré sa
présence à bilthoven il reste toujours
fidèle à ses origines de par son
accident avec sky qui l'a poussé à se
rediriger vers les autres sont savoir
lié à l'ex take et les futurs possibles
affrontements qu'il y aura avec la basse
ville eh bien il ya de fortes chances
pour moi que victor retourne là-bas pour
aider les habitants et pour ce faire il
donnerait vie à biskra qu en gros dans
le lors victor va trouver un golem
abandonné et hors service qui étaient
normalement destinés à aider les gens de
zone dans les tâches quotidiennes ce
golem il va le réparer et surtout il va
lui insérer un cristal extec qui va
totalement upgrade la machine en vrai de
vrai je ne pense pas que bliss ranque
aurait un énorme impact scénaristique
mais bon ce serait un bon petit fan
service sympa quoi néanmoins même si
victor semble faire machine arrière
concernant ces expériences et redevient
en quelque sorte altruiste c'est évident
pour moi que ce ne sera que temporaire
la création de bi trans serait sa petite
rédemption mais il y aura quand même la
chute finale victor est toujours
condamné par sa maladie et l'ex corps
est toujours là il ne sera pas détruit
je vous le garantis en fait l'ex corps
est ce qui symbolise clairement victor
dans league of legends victor se sert de
l'ex corps pour améliorer ses
compétences et pour ce faire l'ex corps
doit lui même évolué sinon lyon le jeu
et la série il semblerait que l'ex
cordes par sa couleur soit encore au
stade de prototype
ce qui nous indique qu'il va encore
évoluer et donc par extension
victor lui aussi jusqu'à arriver au
coeur extec dit parfait avec un victor
complètement métamorphosé
ensuite j'aimerais vous parler de la
présence de noxus dans la série ce qui
est intéressant avec ça c'est que cela
nous montre que même si la série est
basée avant tout sur piles cover et le
prochainement zone et bien cela
n'empêche pas l'intégration des autres
régions et par extension du coup les
champions liés à ces dernières c'était
intelligent de se servir de mails et du
clan médard da pour ça puisque mail et
sa mère servent de liaison entre pull
over et noxus sans avoir à utiliser des
champions comme darius catarina où peu
importe car cela créerait une certaine
incohérence puisqu'ils n'ont rien à voir
avec piles cover et zone à la base mais
surtout il ya maintenant de très fortes
chances pour que noxus soit de plus en
plus présent à l'avenir dans la série
effectivement comme il nous l'a été
montré plusieurs fois dans la première
saison il tower fait énormément
d'affaires avec noxus au point même que
la mère de mme elle a débarqué car la
basse ville devient une menace pour
piles cover et du coup par extension
pour les affaires avec noxus noxus étant
une nation de guerre mg l une des filles
du clan mais darda étant visée par la
tacc de djing ce qui symbolise la basse
ville il est clair que la mère de mme
elle ne va pas en rester là et passera à
l'action soutenant au passage pilote
over a attaqué zone et d'ailleurs cela
pourrait même permettre l'intégration
d'un certain champions déjà avec la mort
de style quot cela va devenir clairement
l'anarchie dans la basse ville avec les
barons de la chimie qui vont
certainement se battre pour avoir le
pouvoir mais surtout afin d'écarter
toute menace de la basse ville pour les
affaires entre pilotes over
noxus et se venger de l'attak aussi
envers sa fille il se pourrait que la
mère de mails fasse venir le bourreau de
noxus sûrs got évidemment son histoire
serait un tant soit peu modifié mais
nous retrouverions les grandes lignes du
nord tout comme pour les autres
personnages de la série en gros hugo est
un bourreau noxiens envoyé à zone pour
une mission malheureusement pour lui
cette mission était un coup monté afin
de l'éloigner de noxus pour que soit ils
puissent faire un coup d'état et prendre
le pouvoir ur god se fera donc attrapé
par les barons de la chimie et sera
réduit en esclavage
au final urgo devait réussir à s'en
sortir et a émergé comme un leader de la
basse ville grâce aux technologies de
zone et autres machineries il va se
transformer en machine de guerre qui va
instaurer un règne de terreur pour les
barons de la chimie et c'est là le point
intéressant c'est que urgo devals
liquider les barons de la chimie un
parent tout en s'entourant des gens
délaissé par ces derniers étant donné
que s'il qu est mort et que les barons
de la chimie vont certainement reprendre
la production de scheiber qui détruit la
cité et tuent les pauvres gens la venue
d'un personnage comme hergott serait
parfaite pour une saison 2 enfin il
serait intéressant aussi de voir
l'impact de jeans dans tout ça avec son
action elle sera certainement adulé par
certains est détesté par d'autres
divisant encore plus la basse-ville
sciure got est envoyé là bas il se
pourrait qu'ils traquent jinks et se
fassent avoir avant de devenir ce qu'il
deviendra pourquoi pas
mais voilà je pense qu'on va s'arrêter
là c'était une petite vidéo chill dédié
à arcanes j'avais trop envie de vous
partager mes idées de vous parler de la
série c'est maintenant chose faite et
j'en suis très content j'espère que cela
vous aura plu alors évidemment on n'a
pas parlé de tout j'ai vraiment hâte que
la saison 2 sortes apparemment ce serait
prévu pour 2023 donc ça va on n'a pas
trop long à attendre n'hésitez pas à
partager vos ressentis et vos idées en
commentaire je vous ai partager ma
vision personnelle je suis vraiment
curieux de savoir la vôtre et puis voilà
moi j'espère voir quand même mon gars
sur israël puisqu'il est plutôt bien
mais bon vu que c'est un explorateur
tout le temps en quête de trésors etc il
voyage tout le temps bah je reste quand
même sur la réserve en attendant vous
pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne et
laisser un petit pouce bleus on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos écouter cet argot rock et que le
lionheart soit avec vous allez ciao tout
le monde
[Musique]